A sentence begins with a capital letter.
A capital letter is a letter that's big.
A capital letter is not a small letter.
A capital letter is big big big.
A sentence ends with a period.
Or an exclamation or a question mark.
A sentence always ends with a period.
So, "My dog is great." is a sentence.
The M is a capital, yeah that's right.
"My dog is great." is a sentence.
It ends with a period, that's right.
And, "Do you like bugs?" is a sentence.
the D is a capital... yeah it's big!
But "Do you like bugs?" is also a question.
Therefore, it ends with a question mark.
And also, "There is a monster!" is a sentence.
the T is a capital... yeah it's big!
"There is a monster!" has a strong feeling.
So therefore it ends with an exclamation mark!
A sentence begins with a capital letter.
A capital letter is a letter that's big.
A capital letter is not a small letter.
A capital letter is big big big.
A sentence ends with a period.
Or an exclamation or a question mark.
A sentence always ends with a period.